LA office building sells for $13.5
million $115 million less than its sale
price a decade ago this is a market
watch
story um page nine page nine here we go
la Aon Center a 62 story office building
Rob can you pull up the picture to see
what it looks like was sold for $153
million marking the largest fourth
quarter deal for office space in the
Western United States as reported by
Newark Group Inc the buyer Carol Wood
LPA La based private Equity Firm
acquired the building located in
downtown LA's Financial District the
property was 64% lease at the time of
sale with diverse tenants including Aon
and Morrison and Forester uh the sale
price represents a significant drop from
his 2014 purchase price of 268 million
unfreaking believe Vinnie from 268
million to $153 million uh depend
pandemic induced challenges in the in
office occupancy contributed to this
decrease with the US office occupancy
rate ranging from 40% to 65% Springer of
2023 Tom you hear the story how much of
this is California how much of this is
real estate how much of this is interest
rates how much of this is just working
from home uh this is California number
one this is 70 I'm so I'm going to say
this this is 70% California you want to
know why if that building was in the
middle of Miami Adam down Miami right
now it would be 80% least in in 90 days
because there's so many uh businesses
have come to South Florida there's
plenty of demand so why is it selling
like this in California there's not
demand why is there not demand it's
California policies taxation you know uh
downtown crime homelessness all around
downtown where do you go if you work in
that building where do you go for lunch
you got to see it downtown folks it's
really bad so I say 70% California and
probably 25% interest rates that's kind
of driving it but look who's buying it
as we predicted a private Equity Firm
swooping in buying undervalued assets
ladies and gentlemen that's their
business and they're and they're
conducting their business very well
right now but that's my take yeah Dana
White said it best Miami is the new La
so you saw what he said when he was
talking I think to the nek boy so shout
out to you Dana White by the way Miami's
pretty packed guys we're good we don't
need anyone else PR up but Miami is the
new La show the um La used to be where
all the cool kids hung out now it's all
Miami La used to be the scene now it's
all Miami sorry it is what it is um but
the reality is this what we've learned
since covid is that residential real
estate has skyrocketed as far as supply
and demand and Commercial Real Estate
has plummeted and whether you call it
WFA or wfh work from home or work from
anywhere a lot of companies simply don't
need all that space and some deals
private Equity firms whether it's even
Black Rock that's buying up a lot of
residential stuff and we talked about
Blackstone whatever's going on with that
the mortgage stuff with Brandon uh they
just don't need all that space and
people are just working from home and
whether it's California and all the
ridiculous laws and red tape that they
put up there and people leaving and
Gavin Newsome being the U-Haul employee
of the year multiple times over it is
what it is at this point in California
so P you if you if you bought something
like that if like you you have a now you
got it basically for half off right it
was half off give her give her TI take
how long do you think somebody could
just buy that and sit on it will it go
back up in price only if you're able to
take that from 60% to 90% 85% the key to
selling a property like you know we're
looking at properties right now the
proper one property we're looking at a
smaller but it's leased at 80% it's 50%
more than another property that's bigger
but it's 100% vacant people are not
buying the property for you know just
how big and massive and beautiful the
proper property is they want to know
who's leasing it who's already in there
and how many years so the way they'll
look at it is they'll look at the list
and they'll say we have 22 tenants these
guys got 19,000 square feet and their at
least expires 2029 these guys have such
and such their at least expires 2032 oh
wow it's a 10-e lease yeah these gu and
then you're like uh okay average about
seven and a half
years got it okay here's the offer they
do the math here's the offer for the
property it's simple as what it is so if
a company like that is buying it they
know they're going to build this place
up and they're going to make their money
they're not worried about whether
they're going to lose money or not the
average person that buys it it's going
to be a different story these guys are
mathematicians they it everything they
buy it's purely logical not emotional
very rarely emotional if it's emotional
it's because it's a very well-known
building this is not an emotional
building so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here